MOSCOW EXPECTHS OUR REPOOM OWN N
UKONG BEEN
FANNIED WITH FALSE NARRATOF
MOSCOW>> WE HAVE RSO
EX IN.EVERY INDICATION WE HAVE Y
ARARED TO GO INT
T PA CENHERE TEE ESCALATINOL
EOECH WHICD IDAY'S DATE -- WASA
CREATED ON WEDAY METADATSI FROT
E TIMINGISE.HE SAMTEL FAUL BOTHW
THINGS W GFRIDAY
THITEP LOT LS SPONTANEOUS.N EXPO
DESTRORMED BUT
THE APPA THE THE.E MASSF CIVIOMO
NDSO.
PICTURES ON RUSSIAN STAT
THEY GET00
RY ARRIVE IT IS TRT OPAY SEPAS.
ISE DRAM A
WAS OFTH POLISBOTEURS O AGE PLA.
EWS CRO, TO CAPTTHANHEN
MIRACULOUS TINORD
FI SOFMATION
ANCE OE VIUKIN OS  COME, THE
DIRECTION INHICHHE
NICK PATONSH>> Reporter:CHRISTI
IS TROUBLING TKEE
THESE NARRATIVES CONAL
BY
VEBOTHIS, ORMATI
T DOES DW THE RECTION IN WHICH
RK PLA INDEE
ON TOO, EIGHT YEARS
WIESVES GUNFIRE  CENTRAL
AGAIN.ERY GOOD POINT.E
NICK PATMUCH.
CIATE IT. NT TO TAKE YOUOW
GERMANY.VICE P
SPOKE TO A SHORT TIME
CORRESPONDENT
BERTRAND HAS BEEN THERE TRKISTEE
REAL.
WHATE DID SHLEADERS THERE?
TO  MORNING
SHE WARNED THAISPOTENTIALLY NE
E L WASINCEN WORLD WAREAR TOS TT
SHE HAS BEEN
ALLIES AND PARTNS INH END TOKET
FIND AS, THIS IS HOW SHE SA.S
KED WHETHER SEIS
U.S. HAS EVIDENCE THAT
THAT THEY LIADE
HAS , WEEVE THAT HAS MADHI
AT AS PARTOFURATNSD
PAHIP AND IN THEON
IN TRY CRITICAL ANUL Reporte SRI
PRINE
EXPRESSESM OVER LAST FEW WEEKS M
THAT A RUSSIAN ATTACD
IMMINENT.SWER THE QUESTIOLY
THE U.S. HAS BEEN SHARIN
PAN NATOND EURE,ALL GET ONTO AEN
FACT ATTACK.ILLING S. ILY -
WILLING T
GOON
OR OCCUPATN T E THATLLLD HER IN
S MORNING TO
SHE  TENANT GENER
COMMANE h ARMY ALL
THE ATLAIC
FORMER SFOTHORECD
ERINNK YOU BH
US.NG TO OURDAY
1945, SINCE WORLD WAR II. RUSSII
BD TO HISTORICAL CONTEXT
FO.IS MEAN FOR THE NTINEND IFIC?
NOT JUST WITHIUKRAINE, BUT WELLU
RE AREQUIREMENTS
UKRAINE IS A SIZT MA
ND IABOUT
TEU'RENG LGEA R AT LARGEA LANDDR
I HEAROF
ERTERM
AT ANDS GOODSCALG ONE CIOSE.E OO
>> IT SEEMULFILLR PUTIS
ALIST I CAN  F
IOMICHAEL, AT THNT
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT, VOLODYMYRZ.
AND YOIN AT -ER CNN THAT TIME F
STATESMANLIKE STYLE OF
ZEA YESTERDAY INUNICH BEFORE WOD
HISE DURING THICRISHIS AD
>>WELL, HE CERINED
UP TTHAT WOULD
S A LOT OFS
ME -- I JUSME IS THHEY WEREABO
GUIDANCE COMING FROM THE PRESIDH
SOT ZELE TEANING
D THAT NOW
R ATSTE OFE BITING
RITISHINOTR S LIFT 2,500
OR SIVEN T
RUSSARNID
FOR EXAM THEDI
RITSCOK THSO-CLE NEEDS TO FEEL E
I THINDI THE FLR  IN TH